I'm joined today by Roger stone who is a
political consultant New York Times
bestselling author and author of the new
book the making of the President 2016
how Donald Trump orchestrated a
revolution Roger you're an in-demand guy
these days it seems everybody including
people in government want to talk to you
did you predict that everything
surrounding what is now going on with
this presidency would would blow up in
the way that it has and that you'd be
such a part of it
well in my book the making you the
president 2016 I really went out of my
way to lay the groundwork to expose this
myth that Donald Trump's campaign
somehow colluded was or was assisted by
the Russians
it's all there in chapter and verse and
of course it requires some update with
the new inferences by members of
Congress who have inaccurately and
falsely accused me of such collusion for
which there is no evidence whatsoever
certainly no evidence that would ever
stand up in a u.s. court of law so I
think it's becoming clearer and clearer
that the whole idea of Russian collusion
with Trump or the Trump campaign was the
excuse the justification the rationale
if you will for surveillance of Trump
Tower and the president and some of his
associates it's certainly according to
the New York Times of January 20th page
one wiretapped data utilized in probe of
Trump associates is the headline that
would be me that my conversations with
Donald Trump were most certainly
monitored during the fall of last year
well now let's dig into that a little
bit right because at the center of a lot
of this is the allegation made by Devin
Nunez who of course is in charge of the
house investigation into potential
collusion between Trump and Russia what
he alleged and whether it's true remains
to be seen is that
in surveillance by American intelligence
agencies of foreign entities that there
were Trump Associates picked up because
they were in communication with those
foreign entities that's very different
than surveillance of conversations
between you and and the president which
I've not seen any evidence for well the
evidence of course would be that all of
my communications were monitored each
email according to the January 30th New
York Times cellphone conversations so
they're by definition my conversations
whether it is with reporters or my wife
or Donald Trump candidate for president
were in fact monitored I also don't
think we're at the end of this scandal
as I have written the path pardon me the
operation dragnet that was put in place
by the NSA right after 9/11 has
monitored a substantial number of
Americans phone calls and the records
indicate coming from a federal lawsuit
in Arizona the Donald Trump was among
those being surveilled so I think this
is a developing story what chairman
Nunez showed us was disturbing because
to be very clear the FBI director mr.
Comey
and ad Mirage errs the NSA director both
said under oath there was no no
surveillance going on at Donald Trump at
Trump Tower and of course that now
proves to be false but it doesn't really
because if someone at Trump Tower was
being surveilled because they were in
contact with a foreign entity that was
being surveilled that's very different
then than surveillance of Trump Tower
itself and I'm wondering if there's a
sort of song I don't agree employed here
to muddy the waters
I don't agree surveillance is
surveillance I think we're going to
learn that there was more surveillance
than we've been told like you I also
have sources and I'm working this story
very hard so let's let that play out
okay I go back I go back to this simple
question which is
if you look at the times of the 20th and
you and again on the 30th the
intelligence sources tell the times that
they have email transmissions they have
copies of financial documents and then
on the 30th they add transcripts of
telephone intercepts between Trump
associates and some Russian contact as
far as I am concerned I'd like to see
them because in my case they do not
exist okay that's fair and let's let's
focus then let's wait for that to play
out and focus on on what's happened so
far I'm genuinely curious as one of
Donald Trump's closest confidants I
don't know how often you speak to him
now but at least at one point why do you
believe that if there is nothing to hide
with regard to the Russia connections
and alleged collusion why do you believe
that so many people have been caught
lying about meetings with Russian
associates and I know not I'm not making
this list for you I know you know it but
for our audience this involves disgraced
National Security Advisor Michael
Flynn's lies about the content of
communications with Russian ambassador
Sergey kis lyac this includes Jeff
Sessions and what we now know to have
been two or three meetings with that
same ambassador you could include Carter
Page Jared Kushner etc aside from
whether or not you believe there was
collusion how do you explain the lies
well I don't have to explain them
because I am none of those people I I
can't tell you what general Flynn may or
may not have done I tend to believe Paul
Manafort who I've known for over 40
years was a UH sure in my wedding mm-hmm
we were we both come from Connecticut we
were active in college and then later
Young Republicans I choose to believe
that he also had no collusion or
contacts with the Russians the fact that
he had a contract with a Russian
oligarch that ended in 2009 an oligarchy
by the way who met privately with John
McCain while he was running for
president does not prove collusion in
this campaign okay but we have to any
more detailed Oh Roger we've got to dig
into that in detail because you're
record I mean on August 15 on the Alex
Jones Show which is a whole other set of
conversations and questions we could
have you said that Paul Manafort has
never worked for the Ukrainian
government or for the Russian government
you said on August 18th on bright boy
that day that is still accurate and that
is still accurate
well only if you want to play a very
muddy semantic game because it's widely
known now that he had multiple contracts
furthering Russian interests and today I
believe that only if you are going in a
semantic direction is that true you've
been proven to have either you didn't
know where you lied about that I have to
disagree with you first of all Russian
government is very specific that's the
Russian state you made reference to
multiple contracts I only have read
about one with this fella Deripaska
mm-hmm
which I was not aware of at the time but
I still don't think it proves Russian
collusion so no again Rossiter I want to
I want every precise language I if we
want to look at precise language you did
tweet on October 31st that Paul Manafort
has no Russian ties that's different
than saying he was again having a ten
million dollar contract is a tie is it
not I would concede that and and look
like he who is without sin cast the
first stone well but that aside I made
that retweet when you made that tweet on
October 31st was it a lie or did you not
know clearly I didn't know about the
Deripaska story because if I had I would
not have said that at the same time I
still think his relationship with
Deripaska does not constitute a
collusion during the 20 2016 campaign
when the contract ended in 2009 okay we
are now starting to starting to hear
from from some Democrats exclusively at
this point that they believe ultimately
some of the individuals associated with
what they believe is collusion or
coordination with Russia will end up in
jail or prison in the United States well
what's your reaction you you think
everybody's gonna get off scot-free here
I'm like
you I would like to see the
investigation I'd like to see these
hearings go forward right but you know
so much more than some of the people
waiting for the investigations of
knowing what you know what's your sense
well that's an assumption on your part
I don't know general Flynn I've never
met him I've never had any
communications with him I know I'm from
watching him on television and and I
cannot tell you what he may or may not
have done and whether any of it rises to
the level of collusion he doesn't join
the campaign until the fall I have no
contact with him and I don't know I've
read Carter pages book he denies
everything I don't know the gentleman
never met him had no dealings with him
best I can tell he appended himself to a
hundred member issue Advisory Committee
as some kind of a Russian expert I'm not
certain who else you're talking about I
don't have a crystal ball but I do know
as far as I am concerned there is no
collusion or coordination of any kind
with any representative of the Russian
state all right let's pick it up there
we've been speaking with Roger stone he
is the author of the new book the making
of the president 2016 how Donald Trump
orchestrated a revolution he's not
kidding that he talks about a lot of
these issues in the book I've been
reviewing it before our interview for
the last week or so let's pause there
and pick up the conversation with him
tomorrow
we're continuing our conversation with
Roger stone he's a political consultant
the New York Times bestselling author
and author of the new book the making of
the president 2016 how Donald Trump
orchestrated a revolution we wrapped up
part one of the interview with some more
general thoughts about what's going on
in in the current investigation let's
see if we can sort out what's true and
what isn't about your involvement in
associations have you ever met
ambassador Sergei kiss lyac I have not
you've never met him and never met him
didn't know his name until I read it in
connection with senator sessions meeting
of course senator sessions is a member
of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee and because he met with the
ambassador you can put a negative spin
on that but we don't know what the cut
with the content or subject of the
meetings is no and Jeff sessions at
first didn't even remember that the
meetings had taken place so I think that
Jeff sessions may not be the best person
to go to to figure out what the content
of the meeting was with regard to the
what's known colloquially as the steel
dossier or the the Trump Russia
blackmail dossier call it what you will
were you on the Miss Universe trip to
Moscow in October of 2013 is that a trip
you were on I was not you were not and I
was with regard to that that trip or any
others can you definitively say that
Donald Trump has not ever consorted with
prostitutes with which is one of those
claims made in the dossier
yeah the dossier is you I think you know
kicked around for quite some time he got
shot during the Republican primaries it
got shopped during the general election
most responsible media organizations
wouldn't touch it it's rife with
misspellings among other things and some
correct assertions as well well the
point I guess I would make is that at
the time of the trip I recall
Keith Schiller who was the head of the
security detail for now president Trump
telling me that his contact the person
assigned to be the contact with the
Trump traveling party on behalf of the
the pageant who resumed ibly was
actually an agent for the government
said that he planned to send girls to
mr. Trump's room and was told under no
circumstances to do so and that Keith
who was a very smart guy posted guards
at both the front and rear entrances of
the hotel as well as the door to mr.
Trump's room also knowing him for 40
years knowing of his germophobia
mm-hmm knowing about his penchant for
privacy and I just find it almost
impossible to believe I think that it is
a whole cloth the idea that Senator
McCain would send this to the FBI
I think that should be examined because
I'd like to know what he knew about the
origins of this document well but John
McCain didn't create the document so
wouldn't the obvious thing to do would
would be to send it to someone who can
maybe try to verify what the claims are
and who the sources I mean you're not
suggesting
unless you're suggesting McCain created
the document it seems the senator stood
out he should have done right send it to
the well I'm suggesting I'm suggesting
as an experienced individual of some
judgment he might have been able to look
at it and see that it is highly
questionable to say the least
too much has already been written about
something that I believe is entirely
fraudulent this did not happen it is so
out of the realm of the possibilities
for Donald Trump if you knew him that it
just has no credibility I also think
that we have traced mr. Steele to a
number of the neo-cons I believe that
that's where this was created the the
fellow who makes these assertions I
think is not credible well hold on a
second go Roger but that I think your
mudding the waters a little bit let's
disaggregate some of those claims it
seems as though steel was initially
hired to do opposition research on Trump
by other Republican candidates but mr.
Steele's credibility has not been called
into question by any serious individuals
you know I don't I don't agree with that
continue but who who that that we can go
to and say they have the knowledge that
we would we would believe people in the
political community who are operatives
like myself are familiar with mr. Steele
and his work he was also involved
peripherally in the case of the
poisoning by presumably the Russians of
a gentleman in London he pops up again
in the in the the Billy Bush tape matter
so I'm not sure that he is the best
source but my understanding was that his
source was a on-the-ground Russian who
made these claims okay let's finalize
the this this top
and then we'll move on to some other
things so you said a lot of things about
how the the prostitution story is not
coherent with your 40-year knowledge of
Trump but are you saying definitively
that to your knowledge Donald Trump has
never consorted with a prostitute not to
my knowledge you know absolutely not
okay you've talked about your
willingness to testify on this issue but
you want to do it openly rather than
behind closed doors
simultaneously you've declined to say
who your mutual friend with Julian
Assange is if asked about that mutual
friend during the open testimony that
you want will you reveal who that
individual is well I think you call it a
source I mean I reported this on my
syndicated radio show I reported it on
my show on him forced I reported it in
my weekly column no I'm not going to
give away a source who turns out to be
right this person is a reporter for a
reputable news organization in the
United States and what they told me was
exceedingly limited that there would be
a data dump on Hillary Clinton in
October and it would be devastating and
then it would include everything which I
took to mean would include some emails
or some documents that had allegedly
been you know erased or deleted at the
State Department
now WikiLeaks essentially on July 31st
in a tweet says really pretty much the
same thing a tweet I was unaware of at
the time so my source is correct
I don't intend to give them up because I
don't want to cost them their job I'm
not going to expose our reporter in that
way but the information they gave me
does not fit the narrative that I knew
in advance and coordinated the scope or
thrust or content of the WikiLeaks
disclosures I also don't buy the idea
that WikiLeaks is a Russian asset it
doesn't matter how many times the
intelligence services want to say this
doesn't make it true even FBI director
Comey said when asked
the house intelligence committees that
their assessment is that that Assange
had or the Russians had used some kind
of cutout that's right it some kind of
middle person yeah assessment to me is
usually a code for four we don't know
but we're guessing you have talked about
the poisoning that you believe you
suffered in January and I want to talk a
little bit about that the the symptoms
I've read you had were fever rash and
hair loss and and you've attributed it
to a poisoning of some kind
well vomiting vomiting diarrhea night
sweats delirium yeah this was not a day
at the beach I don't recommend it for
for weight loss my doctor is convinced
that I was poisoned with some exogenous
substance which may have been
radioactive I have another blood test
this Friday I was very sick can I can I
prove who might have done this or their
motive no okay let's pick it up on it so
number one is have you or would you be
willing to release something from your
doctor saying that their belief is that
the most likely explanation was that you
were poisoned the for what purpose I'm
not an elected official or a public
official I have written my experience
people can make their own judgments okay
I don't I I don't want to dwell on this
I understand that others do because
because it's so if indeed someone tried
to poison you that's a very interesting
story I mean who do you have any sense
of how you might have contracted the
poison before we leave this it could
have been consumed ingested in food or
drink it could have been surface
absorbed that has evidently been done as
you probably also know I was involved in
a hit and run accident this very same
day or the day after the House committee
expressed an interest in my testimony
where we were broadsided the
the car that hit us you couldn't detect
who was driving it because the
windshield was so deeply tinted and they
took off now I find that very suspicious
the car was riding in was was very badly
damaged and perhaps totaled the airbags
went off but whoever hit us didn't
sustain enough damage to their car that
it didn't run like ours threw it in
reverse and took off so that's twice the
the the sickness around Christmas when I
believe I was poisoned happens
immediately after Senator McCain calls
for my testimony the accident if you
want to call it that the hit-and-run yes
was filed with the police with the
Sheriff's Office happens the day after
congressman Schiff and others expressed
an interest in my testimony but Rogers
and I asked the Hat I asked this in a
completely honest and open way if indeed
the goal of either or both of these
incidents was to prevent your testimony
from coming out don't you think that
it's almost sort of like too obvious to
do it when the idea of you testifying is
suggested why it's not like you were
gonna testify the next day why not wait
a little bit it seems incredibly
haphazard well if you are trying to make
the case implausibly and incredibly
crazy as this is that the Russians
wanted to take out stone to silence him
no I'm not making that implication I'm
just genuinely curious why why it would
happen in that way in a way to me to
draw me to it has a certain logic to it
because then you know I don't know who I
don't know if there is a perp and I
don't know what the perps thinking is if
one exists yeah again I don't want to
distract from the fundamental question
of whether we can prove that there were
substantial and meaningful contacts
between anyone of in a position of
authority or influence in the Trump
campaign and the Russians I still don't
think that is the case no I know you
don't think that I know you don't think
that the last thing I want to touch on
and I know you've got just a couple of
minutes left
in retrospect you were one of the
individuals propping up the birther
theories of Barack Obama not being born
in the United States certainly you
encouraged Donald Trump that this is
something he should be public about and
look into number one thing yes your
current that's a slight uh that's a
slight overstatement I was never an
advocate for this point of view but I
learned about his interest in it and he
asked me what I thought and I said you
know follow your conscience if
everything you've read convinces you
that there is something there that's the
thing about Donald Trump no one puts
words in his mouth or ideas in his head
he does not work like a conventional
politician I've written talking points
for you know several presidential
candidates and several presidents Trump
just doesn't operate that way what's
your current belief about the birthplace
of the former president uh you know I
don't know I have looked online at the
document that he produced I have also
read a number of appearing ly
dispassionate you know Internet experts
who questioned whether it's real I have
no idea whether it's real but he's no
longer president I'm not sure why this
is significant if you look at my tweets
feel-good things that I have written it
stone zone.com or don't call - I've
never written on this I've never tweeted
on it but yeah that's fine but you're
not you're saying you don't know that
the president was born in the United
States what would what would convince
you that President Obama was born in the
United States I'm not sure that I can
ever know for sure by the way I'm not
saying that that he wasn't I'm all I'm
saying is I'm not sure but so you're
saying you can't even imagine
hypothetical evidence if it existed that
would convince you that Obama means were
in the u.s. I think it is odd that all
of his personal records are sealed I
think it is odd that it took this long
to produce the birth certificate when he
could have made fools of his critics
much earlier instead this has festered I
think it is true that Donald Trump in a
certain sense was able to bring it
the fringe into a more mainstream
discussion yeah but right now if you're
telling me that if you're telling me
that there's not even hypothetical
evidence that would convince you that
the former president was born in the US
you're not really dealing in the world
of facts you've just decided you'll
never be convinced that that doesn't
seem like a very objective position if
you're saying I couldn't even imagine
evidence that would convince me of it
I'm they don't think no obviously if
somebody wants to if someone wants to
present me with the actual document that
we've seen copies of and it were and it
was certified to be real of course I
would accept it huh but no that's not
going that's not going to happen so I
only know what I have read about this
and I think it's curious at a number of
turns in the road the president says he
was born here it's irrelevant as far as
I'm concerned his presidency is over it
is indeed a fascinating guy yeah far
more important to me it would be the
question of whether people in his
administration illegally unmasked the
names of certain US citizens who are
active in the Trump camp yeah and how
high you know this particular move went
well hopefully we will get answers to a
lot of the questions you and I have
raised during both parts of this
interview the book is the making of the
President 2016 how Donald Trump
orchestrated a revolution we've been
speaking with the book's author Roger
stone thanks for talking to us I know
you've been busy these past few weeks
many thanks for having me I enjoyed it
thank you